all 50 states have agreed to stop using
johnson and johnson's
coveted vaccine for now more than 7.2
million americans have received the one
doe shot
and at least six of them have developed
serious blood clots the cdc and the fda
say the condition appears to be
extremely rare and that's important they
say but they've asked for the vaccine
to pause out of an abundance of caution
that pause is not expected to last long
but there are worries the move will
cause more people to think twice about
being vaccinated nancy cordes is at the
white house for us nancy good morning to
you
good morning tony the cdc is holding a
meeting today to review those six cases
and the fda
is investigating as well as the
president's chief medical advisor dr
anthony fauci says that he anticipates
this pause will last days not weeks or
months and the white house is telling us
that despite this setback they still
believe
they are on track to make sure that
every american who wants a shot
will get one by the end of may vaccine
sites across the country had to make a
quick
pivot away from johnson and johnson
tuesday
as states began canceling some
appointments and rebooking others for
different vaccines
a little sad because i like the one and
done fda officials recommended the pause
after
six women in the u.s developed serious
blood clots
it's out of an abundance of caution
johnson johnson described it as an
extremely rare disorder
as governors downplayed the news
hopefully this is just a
a small setback that we will overcome
this is an abundance of caution
but behind the scenes in a conference
call with white house officials
state leaders expressed frustration the
ability for governors to reinstill
confidence after something like this is
a hundred times harder
than putting the problem in the first
place kent koster the public health
director in kentucky's purchase area
told
us he's concerned yesterday's
announcement will deter
some people from getting any of the
vaccines that is just frustrating for
the providers because we know
you know we're there we're ready you
know to give the vaccine
but the people just aren't coming in the
white house insists the pace of
vaccinations will not change much
about 95 percent of the supply so far
has come from pfizer
and moderna there's enough vaccine that
is
basically a hundred percent
unquestionable
for every single solitary american dr
anthony fauci told cbs evening news
anchor and managing editor nora
o'donnell
recent recipients of the j j shot should
look out for symptoms
including severe headache chest
discomfort and difficulty breathing
it appears that this adverse event
occurs within
like between six days and 13 days so if
you're
beyond four weeks and you've had it a
month or two ago
i think you really don't need to worry
about anything monica roberts-jenkins
falls into that category
it's been maybe about four weeks now the
houston paralegal says
she would get the shot again there's
side effects pretty much with anything
that we take
right whether it's you know surgeries
medicines
whatever health experts still have not
determined to what extent if any the
johnson and johnson vaccine contributed
to
these very rare blood cots but there is
promising news this morning
about the two other vaccines that are
available
to americans moderna released updated
data
showing that its covid vaccine is more
than 95 percent
effective against severe cases six
months
after the second dose and pfizer ceo
yesterday announced that the company
would be boosting production and
delivering
10 percent more doses to the us by the
end of may
than previously announced anthony yeah
both very encouraging numbers nancy
thank you